que diriez vous d'un petit peu de
sociologie journée sur social interxion
trainer où il m'a dit bonjour schmale
pauli alors c'est un jeu dans lequel
nous sommes face à des situations plus
ou moins gênantes et nous contrôlons
uniquement les yeux de notre personnage
vous savez que les yeux en disent
beaucoup sur le fond de notre pensée cf
lie to me qui la regarde à gauche ça
veut dire qu'il cherche dans des
souvenirs qu'elles existent paris tu as
raison mais pourquoi tu es aussi stylée
à ce que je suis le héros d'une série on
a ce monologue bref on a beaucoup parlé
à là on a failli faire un trou plus long
que le v12 ça va pas du tout donc on
contrôle les yeux du personnage comme ça
et on va apprendre à faire face à ces
situations de merde utilise ton regard
pour interagir socialement avec le
caissier boyard alger dans cette
situation elle nous parle infopub je les
regarde là je regarde les courses
ouais c'est ça hein et là je le regarde
du castrum en parler cela tout me lie to
me urinoirs ça c'est extrêmement gênant
utilise l'urinoir à côté c'est là que
c'est dure normalement quand tu vois
toilettes
il ya trois urinoirs ya un mec ici et tu
vas là quand c'est pas le cas c'est vrai
que tu es un peu mal mais la mecque qui
a été aux yeux juste tu regarde en bas
tu regardes tu regarde juste ton énorme
tronc d'arbre ne permettez pas votre
regard de s'éloigner de votre tâche
mais l'attaché ccc ça n'en faut que je
regarde lui elle a regardé il va
regarder [ __ ] battu quoi je regardais
bill blaikie
[Musique]
regardez les parties intimes de
quelqu'un d'autre n'est pas encourageant
ça va ça peut être parce que je suis
surpris de cette chose imposante
julliard dans l'air moi je te bute à
regarder les parties intimes de l'autre
un minimum mais on fait ça mais ça ne
regarde jamais le celui du voisin un peu
mais pas trop je repasse sur moi un
petit peu tout doux tout doux
je me sens mais non il faut que je
regarde un certain temps sinon il le
prend mal
1 2 je passe à - 0 et non 1 2 j'en passe
au mans 1-2 voilà vue qui m'a regardé il
a vu que certains réel son truc
il est content et je crois que ça passe
voilà c'est ça il fallait qu'il me voit
en train de voir son pénis en vrai dans
cette situation il embrouille
tu fais quoi moi je vais du 93 58 93
c'est que tu viens pas du 93
le transport annonay du bac c'est le
coup de la jolie fille qui tous les
jours quand tu vaux travail c'est elle
qui s'assoit à côté de toi tu connais ni
son nom ni son prénom ni son âge mais tu
connais ses mensurations mais tu n'es
pas un pervers lol c'est parti assez ça
je le savais qu une conversation avec ta
partenaire de transport c'est
certainement pas à fait partant car dans
certaines vallées mais c'est comme ça
elle a eu peur par ta tentative
d'interaction et je comprends le mieux
c'est de faire genre tu lis le livre
c'est balzac j'ai lu son oeuvre
lacharrière rien et là ça a marché à ce
même parler je me mets à lui parler lie
to me prête je regarde en l'air
tu es gêné devant cette situation le
café à ses la même fille assez la fille
du bus on a eu son numéro et on la
revoit au café le lendemain c'est
incroyable fait bonne impression pour
ton premier rendez vous attendent en
cours c'est une bonne question est ce
que c'est pas comme le délire de
l'urinoir est-ce qu'il faut pas qu'elle
me voit en train de regarder son
décolleté pour qu'elle se sente bien bon
abri tu te prennes gmail mais café jus
apparemment il n'a pas eu connais
beaucoup de filles il n'a pas connu
beaucoup du riz noir non plus beau avoir
brassé partie je te regarde pendant que
tu me parles oui regard je suis poli je
regarde tes boules au point mort pendant
que je parle je regarde en l'air comme
toi genre je réfléchis oh là là je te
raconte ma journée d'hier
merci à pas perdre sa part bien sympa
les bulls les boobs tu as regardé dans
le vent autrefois
[Musique]
merde etc s'il faut que je fasse je peu
louche et elle me regarde dans je louche
elle tape une mare est ce que quelqu'un
a déjà réussi à séduire une fille parce
qu'ils la louche et ça m'intéresse
énormément n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un
mail
ok ça part sur un parent car c'est la
même fille qu'on emmène un deuxième
rendez vous oui quoi de mieux que les
lots parc hop je regarde en l'air
pendant que moi je parle puis j'ai
regardé je vous regarde dans les yeux
fixes dans les yeux on n'a pas perdu en
brouille ta vous avez vu qu'on regarde
qu'on le filme pas d'un visuel en
profite à elle sur un scénario merde
vous avez agi trop violemment la
situation s'est aggravée à lui pour le
coup c'est le vrai avec du 9 3 la règle
des deux secondes à et la junte un
trucage faire n'importe quoi avec les
yeux mais peut-être ça a passé
donc là je le fixe et dès que je mets à
parler je vais louche et voilà jamais ça
je crois que c'est la vraie sociologie
[ __ ] mais là le mec déjà il a envie de
thomas rabe la gueule et ensuite c'est
sûr et certain et part avec ta copine
même tes parents il adopta copine ils
veulent plus de toi watch la chose
suivante c'est la romance qu'est ce que
la romance achètent des préservatifs
ça c'est affreux mon petit technique
vous avez un distributeur automatique et
vous mettez un foulard plus une capuche
plus un masque de ski il fait très froid
dehors en plus c'est crédible mais si
vous craquez que vous allez au monoprix
du coin on va regarder les préservatifs
please do zombo l'intérieur brice ne pas
marc monnet votre souffle ok je passais
le dire mais ça marche bon j'ai un
regard elle est mal géré du mal à l'aise
balle normal je crois qu'il faut
alterner super vite
oui oui c'est beau c'est ça jean-claude
à la caisse pour les capotes molsheim à
un entretien d'embauché
c'est ma première fois ce parti
dépistage en direct il faut le
convaincre de te prendre
il se passe quoi que son pays attache
pas travailler pour cet homme attendre
herbe
l'interview a grillé que tu dévisageait
son oeil tu ne seras pas recruter merde
[ __ ] tu as peut-être faut mettre son
oeil droit
si je louche tu me prends en bas c'est
drôle et ça m'a permis de sortir de
beaucoup de situations méfie toi mais en
fait je pense qu'il faut que je regarde
un endroit où je lui parle mais il faut
que quand j'ai à cet endroit il me
regarde pas comme ça ces interminables
mext entretien l'interviewer à mal placé
votre demande ne soient pas recrutés
bon tu sais quoi je vais devenir
youtuber voilà les billets bientôt ils
sont là [ __ ] comment je vais expliquer
ça à clotilde la fin de ma vie que j'ai
rencontrés dans le bus donc ses parents
sont au courant s'en bat les couilles
merde c'est mes parents ou ses parents
ne soient pas trop gêné pendant sa
rencontre avec ses parents c'est parti
la maman bajard yard ma copine part je
regarde là on parlera garde c'est de ne
pas péter pas dans cette situation
vraiment plus en avant dans cette vidéo
plus la sociologie elle s'en va comme ça
après à l'athéna stratosphère comme ça
elle tombe elle reste de repas m diq ma
blague et nuls comme la douche et je
vais louche et nantes on l'a remarqué
utiliser tout je loupe merde comment je
fais pour ne pas louper
mais pour ne pas paraître teubé tête
faut mixer c'est bon fall est louche et
quand changer de regard personne a
grillé fait bonne impression devant son
père
[Musique]
il fallait nous fait le coup et il adore
ça robert s'en tordre fait bonne
impression avec sa mère ok je viens de
chien vous qui me revient vers la mer
j'ai un chien
bon j'ai un comprimé ça a marché
apparemment c'est assez comme dans la
vraie vie ça il t'aime bien mais tu sais
pas pourquoi
bravo vous êtes le bienvenu dans la
belle famille et on finit sur une bonne
note
merci d'être venus aux coups n'oubliez
pas demain h 34 fait les six exercices
et bonne occasion vous serez lire sur
les visages comme moi je regarde en haut
à gauche tu as oublié là qu'est la vidéo
fdp
pour savoir si vous regardez la vidéo je
vous aime un peu d'amour ça fait plaisir
n'oubliez pas les mêler de ça vous a plu
sinon le made you lie to me lève à venir
vous casser les cheveux c'était cool ce
petit jeu même si la moitié des
situations c'est du bullshit
l'autre moitié est quand même assez vrai
j'ai quand même beaucoup aimé parce
qu'elle avait un petit côté sociologie
qui me plaît énormément
j'aurais aimé que ce soit un peu plus au
sérieux que la blague du proust par
exemple fois c'est minable
est ce que serait pas l'hôpital qui se
fout de la charité squeeze qui a fait ça
elle faisait bon j'aime bien savoir
garder forte aux mille indiens du monde
[Musique]